she's so shy why she's so shy there's
two cameras on here not just for last
time she's like there's two daddies we
are at Christina's house we're gonna be
filming a month bung for their channel
so you can check it out on their Channel
I don't know when it's gonna come out
keep an eye out for that and we're here
we get to hang out with Leah but she
just went for a nap so I'm like
girlfriend can I join you cuz I'm sleepy
too we overslept today like crazy it's
almost 2:00 p.m. we woke up about like
two hours ago cuz last night we went to
the movies we saw midsummer that was a
crazy movie it was pretty crazy but not
as intense as I thought it was gonna be
like you were hyping it up it was
disturbing but it wasn't as like I don't
think was that crazy it was like more
artsy than it was for Omaha I actually
thought it had kind of a happy ending
and I know I'm really twisted for saying
that if you've seen the movie but I
thought it was kind of a happy ending
but um but yeah so we went to the
theater yesterday Isaac's in Laughlin
with his daddy
so he's not with us but yeah we're just
hanging out with their friends and
getting out of the house because we had
no
this weekend doing this well tomorrow
you actually have plans you're gonna go
see wax I do damn
I shot a music video like over a year
ago now - maybe even two years ago yeah
but he's never had a plan to release it
but now he's finally releasing it it's a
number or or scrambling the team back
together for one more editing session
and I'll meet up with wax and 8k
tomorrow so then when that video finally
comes out if peanut bird is involved so
peanut butter music video I think I
actually really love that song you think
that all the time but anyway you guys do
things legit you got a b-roll you got
lights you got a setup I'm actually if
you only for the vlog I think you'd be
rolling for the muck Potter this
interaction here yeah videos not a
deception right are we good to go
is that a commercial yeah at the end of
your sip - how was the pump it was fun I
am feeling a stomach ache now no no no
so it was um it was all about like
pregnancy cravings missed out that's why
she's complaining right now that looks
mom can we get invited back for a laya
mukbang yeah
and that popsicle though that possible
bomb but yes so right now we're planning
to go swimming but before we swim we're
gonna go take aunt Kristina and Leah to
go check out our plant a home that we
talked about in the last video
oh you got multiple plans yeah like an
aunt at a to name it so I'm just like
planning yeah and they're like you know
plan B or Plan C whatever plant azar our
dream home pretty much for this starter
home and we're gonna take them to go see
the place exciting house shopping is
always exciting hmm we're so adulting
[Music]
thank you you got me right now share the
moustache your goatee of blueberry she's
like you're not really eating it I know
you're not maker so I've become Leah's
footrest this seems relaxed we're
feeling good
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes um after this is when we are
planning to go swimming it's 6 p.m.
we'll see if we end up swimming today
because I fear that I might be too cold
in the theatre but hopefully not because
I so many always relaxing true there is
a hot tub Jacuzzi brand new when I eat
at chick-fil-a it's always a toss-up
between the Polynesian sauce which is
always a crowd favorite and sweet and
spicy sriracha this one tastes like that
a Thai chili sauce my mom would always
cook like fry a fish and make sure we'll
just toss like this this flavor of sauce
on top of it that brings me back
really I know she just buys the chopped
Thai chili sauce that that's the story
but she fries the fish that my home yeah
I registered that wrong
what's your favorite sauce what's your
go-to sauce at chick-fil-a everyone has
a sauce the chick-fil-a Polynesian
Polynesian high-five I I can appreciate
the chick-fil-a sauce too but oh no
might be kind of it I tend to just mix
up catch up with Polynesian that's my
go-to true true what about you guys you
guys have like a goat cheese sauce
chick-fil-a I'm just like to instill
Polynesian when I use that for the fries
mmm the chick-fil-a I use for the
burgers so I put on top of the burger
night true is it her burger if it's a
chicken-fried chicken sandwich steak is
missing pickles but there's a pickle in
there oh yeah you really like Polynesian
sauce
okay so we didn't end up making it to
the pool we ended up just eating
chick-fil-a relaxing and talaxian and
then we started talking because you know
Christina 17 weeks pregnant now we're
just talking about it so cool you guys
have your second baby and then they're
like well what about you guys and we're
like oh no we're just kind of going with
the flow and then I was like did you
guys ever like do any of those
oscillations just kind of stuff which is
like we actually have a ton leftover do
you want that I don't like sure so then
they ended up giving us their ovulation
sticks since they don't mean it anymore
so according to my app though this is a
week to test so we don't know
[Applause]
all right get pregnant kit right here so
I don't know we'll see in a month of
this work thank you guys sending you
baby does oh my goodness because if a
kiss yes yes cool I hear a bug going
anywhere
fine fine go to your mama okay you want
your kiss daddy she wants a cake
everyone gets
Oh baby
oh this is so funny the way we're in it
we're leaving this house with this with
more gifts cuz actually gifted of this
we didn't get in our vlog but and gave
Casey a walk and then they gave us these
um Apple coating chamoy things to make
these apples really delicious we're
leaving with a lot of stuff thanks guys
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]